are you guys doing let me start by
saying the the footage we saw this
morning as spectacular absolutely loved
it I'm curious before filming began what
was your favorite Queen song and now
what is your favorite Queen's Own start
the film and then every song that we
covered in the film now has special
resonance for me because we kind of
lived it for a while but particularly I
think love my life will always have a
special place in my heart because that's
how we finished the film performing that
song so it's the last sequence we did it
kind of stands for the whole journey of
the film and all the people involved in
it the cars the crew coming together for
that last moment on wrap every new song
that we did became my new favorite Queen
song like as we performed it you learned
something about that song you became you
learned how to play it or there was
something about it you were like oh
that's the one I love and then that kind
of went on I feel like throughout the
entire process it was very strange I
loved the song save me
but after filming I think we are the
champions because we did live eight on
the vent on my very first day of filming
and then my event on the very lost so
kind of perfectly book ended the whole
experience radio Gaga was the first song
that I learned the the actual
choreography for so that has a special
place in my heart
somebody to love may or may not be the
first thing you hear in the film and we
wrapped my last day of shooting I was to
love of my life so I did three but those
were for obvious reasons are very
special to me now
I completely understand for each of you
often it's the when you're playing a
real person from what I've heard from
other actors it's that first thing that
you figure out that gets you into the
character and I'm curious for each of
you what was that first thing
that sort of made it so you could you
know you felt comfortable in the okay we
had little triggers we gonna Center for
my for me that's very interesting that
was like the little thing I don't have
to like keep saying to myself to get me
into it yeah all right all right
for this one I have one thing it was
just kind of it's that thing where you
put on the costume and with the hair and
makeup and I had a series of wig so it
was kind of dependent on that as well it
just kind of sets you into it and you
move differently and you hold yourself
differently then that's the kind of at
the moment did you have a safe word yet
my in was the word okay just that and
then the squint John deacons always
squinting so it kind of like look up
into the light a lot and just sort of
get that going and then I'd feel like
once that began then I could you know
we'll get the rest of it down we all had
like interviews that we went back to on
YouTube as well every morning and would
just be there every morning was kneeling
on the way in you can't look at I
interview another your go to use
check-in and go okay that's good that's
good
Brodie's merck freddie mercury's posture
is impeccable so that was something i
kept reminding myself and I will again I
already have to stop I'm just gonna say
again the footage looked [ __ ] awesome
thank you thank you so much for giving
me some time